in beirut public anger is mounting as
residents their demand the lebanese
government take
responsibility for the deadly blast that
rocked the city this week
50 people were killed and 5 000 others
injured when several tons of highly
combustible
ammonium nitrate exploded at a warehouse
mts taya reports from the lebanese
capitol this morning
on the rising tensions in the city
well the shellshock residents of this
shattered city are taking to the streets
in major anti-government protests
they're calling
a day of judgment for their leaders they
blame
for this devastation
the rage on beirut's ruined streets runs
deep
and these running street battles between
protesters and security forces
exposes a hard truth
that the city's citizens haven't just
lost everything
they've lost complete faith in their
leaders and their fury
is now bottomless as rescue workers
arrive from around the globe
the lebanese president only poured fuel
on the fire
by refusing on friday to allow for an
independent international investigation
into the causes of the explosion
left with the leadership they blame for
the blast and whose well-documented
corruption
and incompetence led to financial
collapse over the past
year the commitment beirut's residents
are now showing to each other
is extraordinary across the shattered
city are armies of young volunteers
armed with brooms brushes and dustpans
sweeping away glass
and debris all on their own the
government
is doing nothing we are doing everything
help us
the epicenter of the blast has become
something of a morbid meeting point for
survivors
my dad is underground including tatiana
whose father worked at the port he and
many others
are still missing since the explosion
what would you say to him
if he could hear you that i love him we
are all waiting for him everybody is
searching for him
says she's furious lebanon's leaders
have failed her
and her father i think lebanon deserves
more than this better than this
and we deserve better too the explosion
spared no one
not even a mother giving birth a child
brought into the world in darkness
that for so many in beirut still hasn't
lifted
now with lebanon's leaders refusing an
independent international investigation
it's hard to see how any of them might
be held accountable
for this disaster perceivious this
morning saturday
impious time favorite